So Leute, auf gehts, gerade mal gucken ob Teams nicht wieder meinen Sound verstellt
hat.
Wahrscheinlich, ich hör mich schon irgendwie merkwürdig an.
Ja, natürlich, was sonst, Teams ist so eine kacke Software, alter, lull, so, mal gucken,
Twitch hat noch nicht registriert, dass der Stream online ist, so wie es aussieht.
Das bin ich einmal und zweimal Abobox Camper.
Gebt euch zu erkennen, wer sind die Abobox Camper.
Yep, oh, bisschen groß das ganze hier.
So, ja, ich, letzten Drücker, ich bin gerade eben erst reingekommen.
Ich muss erstmal meinen Vorschau, Stream Vorschau anmachen, von alles, dass ich überhaupt was
sehe.
So, oh, meine Maus geht nicht auf der zweiten Seite, natürlich auch exzellent.
Huge, extrem exzellent ist das.
So, also wo gibt es denn heute den offiziellen Stream, ist das auf Twitch, Xbox, müssen wir
mal wieder gucken, was da schneller ist.
Ja, ja, dismiss, skip, Skype, ich stelle euch mal vor, ich habe immer noch Skype im Autostart,
ne, das kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen.
Warum auch immer mal Skype noch im Autostart hat, aber ich habe es irgendwie geschafft,
kegweight.
Hoffentlich besser als damals, 2003, oh, Alter, was ist jetzt los, MonkaS, MonkaS, MonkaS,
geht es hier, ah, hier geht es, ok, ich glaube, das kenne ich, ich glaube, das kenne ich,
der ist ja auch nicht mehr da hier, das war, jetzt hat der Phil Spencer am Start, das war
Dingsirvisa, Den, Den oder Don Mattrick, glaube ich, oder so in der Richtung, irgendwie so,
vielleicht weiß es nur einer von euch, so, ich muss gerade mal meinen Vorschaurechner
machen, der irgendwie nicht will, warum auch immer, kegweight, Microsoft, Maus, ja, starten
und geht es jetzt, ah, jetzt, exellent, jetzt funktioniert es, ich muss nämlich meine Vorschau
anmachen, dass ich chat und alles sehe, wirklich hier voll auf den letzten Drücker jetzt, jetzt
funktioniert es, sehr schön, sehr gut, passt alles, zack, jetzt sind wir, jetzt sind wir
am Start, so, jetzt muss ich mir erstmal einen Stream raussuchen, ja, Xbox One Reveal 2013
Highlights, da gab es nicht so viele Highlights, ne,
das war so fail, das war so, ach du Scheiße war das fail, ich kann mich noch dunkel dran
erinnern, Alter, Japadi, wer interessiert das dann,
Xbox Go Home stimmt, er ist jetzt am Drücker, ja, wann geht's los, in 5 Minuten, ich muss
immer noch einen Stream suchen, ok, Twitch, Xbox, wo gibt's denn den Stream hier, ah hier,
das ist doch wunderbar, das war so fail, echt, Moment, gab's die, gab's die, gab's die,
gab's die wirklich, Moment, Moment, Moment, gab's die ernsthaft, ne, nicht wirklich,
oder, ne, ne, ne, die haben Oktober 2019 angefangen zu filmen, gibt noch nix, gibt noch nix, gibt
noch nix, null, das ist ja mal fail, 2021, 2021 soll das rauskommen, 2021, die haben
das 2013 angekündigt, oh ne, Alter, der Kerl, der darf natürlich nicht fehlen, der hier
darf nicht fehlen, ne, hey, ich mein, ich kenn sogar einen, der kennt einen, der kennt
ihn, ja, richtig VIP, Alter, ich sag nur, ich sag nur, Xbox Call of Duty Fastpass, falls
Call of Duty, Call of Duty, Call of Duty, Call of Duty, Call of Duty, Call of Duty als
So, ähm, auf geht's, eine Minute.
Oh.
Style... Moment.
Erstmal neu laden, das scheint zu hängen.
Wupp wupp wupp wupp wupp wupp wupp wupp wupp.
Das ist das beste FFZ Addon hier, dieser Kompressor für Twitch Streams.
Weil da hast du automatisch, wenn irgendeiner scheiß Quali hat, ist instant die Quali halt nicht besser vom Mikro, aber die Quali halt besser, weil's ausgewogener klingt irgendwie.
Gibt's den Stream auch auf Mixer? Sehr gute Frage.
Äh.
Nein.
Gibt das nicht auf Mixer.
Mixer ist doch ab anscheinend, ja?
Okay, it's happening, Leute, it's happening, jetzt geht los.
Excellent.
Excellent. Sagt, ob's zu laut, zu leise, zu sonst was ist, aber erst mal warten, wenn wir einen hören.
Pause-Champ.
Ah, geht los.
Yep.
Äh.
Ah, Moment, der Countdown zu Null war noch nicht genau, jetzt brauchen wir noch einen neuen Countdown.
Ach, Chat.
So.
Weird-Champ.
Halo.
Da Master Chief.
Das muss Halo sein.
Ist das so?
Master Chief ohne Chief.
Ist doch gar keiner drin.
Wir sind im Anzug.
Aha.
Was?
Excellent Pilot-Skills?
Warum sind die alle so akron drauf immer?
Ich mein, ich würd mich freuen, wenn ich den Master Chief am Schiff fährt, dann wirst du wissen, wie ich ihn überleb's.
Ah.
Es sieht halt aus, wie Halo aussieht, Leute.
So sieht Halo halt aus, so sah Halo schon irgendwie gefühlt immer aus.
Ich mein, der sieht jetzt nicht Absolut Bleeding Edge 2020 aus, ne?
Aber Halo hat bis auf das erste ja noch nie wirklich, ähm, jetzt so wahnsinnig geil ausgeschaut.
Und das erste sah auch nur geil aus in der Demo, die damals für den PC angekündigt wurde.
Und dann auf der Xbox kam, sah es auch noch geil aus, aber nicht so übertrieben, nicht von dieser Welt geil.
3D Map.
Ist die Lautstärke eigentlich okay vom Stream?
Oder soll ich Streamticken leider lauter machen?
In Wirklichkeit ist das nicht Infinite, sondern Halo 1 Remastered.
Weil das hier und auch mit dem Hintergrund konnte ohne Probleme Halo 1 sein.
Wo ist die Musik?
Ne sehr gute Frage.
Gerade bei Halo wird man eigentlich auf fast dauerhafte Soundtrack Beschallung jetzt wertlegen.
Oh jetzt, jetzt.
Als nächstes kommt noch der Battle Royale Modus.
Ne, mit Copyright kann das mit der Musik hier wenig zu tun haben, die ist ja, das ist ja ein Stream von Microsoft, äh, mit Microsoft Inhalten.
Die müssen einfach keinen striken und gut ist.
Guck mal, man hat jetzt so einen Hook.
Den gab's im letzten doch nicht, oder?
Ich hab das aller, ich hab das, das letzte Halo nicht gespielt.
Das, das, ähm, ich weiß gar nicht mehr wie das hieß das davor.
Das letzte Halo was ich gespielt hab, ist das mit dem, mit dem, ähm, Forerunner Typ.
Es sieht halt original aus wie Halo aussieht, halt, halt nach Halo.
Was kann man hier all zu viel zu sagen jetzt?
Die Waffen wirken einen Tick automatischer beziehungsweise mehr Burst, wie in den alten Halo Teilen.
Ach guck mal, jetzt kann man sich, ach, ich dachte das ist ne Schildbatterie oder sowas, weil normalerweise Burst den Halo ja keine Schilder sammeln.
Also, was mein ich, das lädt hier auf.
Ich halte ihn aber schon mal zugute, sie zeigen einfach mal Gameplay als erstes.
Ist das Xbox One Gameplay? Äh, gute Frage, ich weiß es nicht.
Alarm, Alarm.
Das ist ein komischer Cut.
Come on.
Aber hier wirst du jetzt stehen.
Dies ist mein letztes Kampf.
Ein echter Test der Legenden.
Unser Tor wird uns beide verlassen.
Der Arthrit.
Ahja. Alles klar.
Dauert nicht mehr lang.
Okay, es war Halo, der Rest war absolut nichts sagend.
Aber es war eindeutig Halo.
Und es hätte Halo-ige nicht aussehen können.
Wir hoffen, dass ihr den ersten Blick auf die Halo Infinite-Kampagne genossen habt.
Ich bin sehr stolz auf das Team von 343.
Und wir sind froh, euch einen Hinweis auf die epischen Wettbewerbe, die euch auf den nächsten Teil der Master Chiefs Journey erwarten.
Dies ist die amüsierendste Kampagne, die wir in 343 kreiert haben.
Für das erste Mal werden die Spieler die Freiheit haben, einen mysteriösen neuen Halo Ring zu besuchen,
der mehrere Mal größer ist als unsere letzten zwei Halo Games.
Ich weiß, es heißt Halo wegen dem Ring.
Ich finde es aber geil, wie die bei jedem Halo oder bei fast jedem Halo sich einen neuen Halo Ring aus dem Ärmel schütteln.
So, das ist der letzte Halo Ring, der letzte jetzt.
Nächster Teil.
Ho, guck mal da.
Da ist ja noch einer.
Irgendein Survival-Game?
Oh nee, ist das Pupke? Das ist nicht Pupke, oder?
Nee, nee.
Das ist doch die aus Uncharted.
Nee, ist sie nicht.
Sieht ihr, sieht ihr aber echt ähnlich.
Ja.
Am besten, man ist nachts alleine umzingelt und dann schreit man nochmal so richtig, dass jeder mitkriegt.
Guck mal, da ist ja sie.
Ok, was könnte das sein?
Was? Irgendein Survival-Ding?
Das ist wahrscheinlich nicht Pupke.
Was könnte das sein?
Bis jetzt haben wir auch noch keine Zombies oder sonst fast gesehen.
Oh, Zombies.
Zombie-Kirsche.
Ok.
Wie war 1 und 2 so?
Da ist er ja.
Ich finde ihn geil. Der steht immer so wahnsinnig überzeugt da. Müsst ihr euch mal angucken.
Vor 10 Minuten.
Oh, ich habe keinen Game Pass mehr.
Der Aschenbecher ey.
Das ist Forza, oder?
Ja.
Forza.
Ja, Autospiele eignen sich immer richtig gut dafür.
Die zeigen fast in jedem Konsolen-Ankündigungs-Ding oder Forze immer ein Rennspiel noch dabei am Anfang.
Wow, Premier.
Also es ist RTX off, aber Raytracing on.
Also es ist rtx off, aber raytracing on.
Engine heißt ja nichts wirklich, das heißt nur es ist halt nicht vorgerendert mit irgendwas
anderem, aber echtes gameplay mag was anderes sein, außerdem finde ich Autorennspiele übelst
resident sleeper, wie, was, war es das jetzt, what the fuck, man hat ein Auto gesehen was
aus seinem garage fährt, einmal im kreis und fertig, ah, ich, haben wir das nicht schon
gesehen, nee, nee, ist doch was anderes, tanzer, dankeschön, ahja, ja,
es gibt denn das, wenn es fertig ist, ja, erstmal schöne runde ins wasser kotzen,
was, was machen die da, sind das eigentlich satanistische Rituale oder was
gibt das, ah nee, healspell, ganz schön lange castzeit, ok, ich kann mir absolut nichts
darunter vorstellen, aber sah nett aus, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
Keine ahnung was es ist aber
Es ist
Ich liebe dich, du siehst, was ich sehe. Oh, Kokona. Es ist nicht egal, dass sie uns nicht glauben.
Wir alle glauben, dass das gestern Abend ein Selbstversuch war, aber wir konnten nicht sicher sein.
Es ist nicht egal, dass sie uns weggehalten haben. Bruder, Schwester, wir schauen uns für einander an. Es ist nicht egal, dass es nicht möglich ist, die Wahrheit zu finden.
Wir sind alle fertig mit Fairy Tales. Die einzige Sache, die wichtig ist, ist, dass du mein Bruder bist.
Sie liebte dich. Sie hat dich getroffen. Wir haben es beide gesehen.
Ich dachte, hierher kommen würde ein Kapitel unseres Lebens enden.
Nichts Gutes kommt aus erhebenden Erinnerungen.
Wir haben wirklich keine Wahl darüber.
Es ist immer eine Wahl, Sohn.
Ich kann das nicht.
Hör auf!
Bis ich dich wieder sehe.
Moment, hatten sie das nicht schon mal gezeigt?
Wie hieß das noch mal jetzt?
Ich hab jetzt auf den Titel. Hatten sie das nicht schon mal gezeigt?
Irgendwas tell me?
Das haben die doch schon mal gezeigt.
Wir arbeiten auf einer sehr, sehr speziellen Version von Ori und der Wille der Wisps.
Spezifisch für Xbox Series X.
Wir sind jetzt in einem Zeitpunkt, in dem wir Fadality und Framereien erreichen können,
die vorher absolut unmöglich waren.
Ein bereits wunderschöner Spiel wie Ori kann nun mit 120 Hz Framereien
in vollem 4K HDR in ihrer höchsten Qualität,
mit silky-smooth-Animation, super-krisp-scharp-Image
und niedriger Input-Latency.
Das ist so wichtig für die feste und präzise Plattform.
Wir können auch die Immersion in unterschiedliche Späße in unserem Welt
durch Premium Audio-Tech, die wir vorher nicht real-time simulieren konnten.
Und mit all diesen Plattformen, die wir haben, können wir unseren Spielern
noch mehr Möglichkeiten haben, wie sie unser Spiel spielen wollen.
Wir können nicht warten, dass alle von euch diese sehr spezielle Version von Ori
in der Xbox Series X zum Alternativen Ende machen.
Pum.
Miracle truck und put you on the wrong side of a gun
Or sword or this thing
Danger
Intrigue
Trust no one
Das schockt mich jetzt nicht. So was will. You find on Gorgon?
This unit and when you any drinks in its current state
Ach ist der obsidian am mitmischen okay, die machen eigentlich dann sind wir ziemlich gutes zeug
If you're waiting for the biggest game of the year zum teufel ist der pedo bär simulator
Ah the fuck
But if you're ready for the smallest we've got you covered from obsidian entertainment the makers of games that are nothing like this one
What this summer strive together to thrive together or just feed your friend to the spiders and go solo
Spur das
What the fuck warum sitzt dann in bettel traut rum
Okay, kein plastenschirmer was das jetzt war
Ich dachte es war zum zweiten
Now it's great is you're gonna be able to play the multi-layer
Xbox game preview and on steam early access
Ich glaube ganz ehrlich leute das ist ein game das sieht im trailer cool aus und am ende
langweilig
World premiere
We have always known noch mehr obsidian wie viele leute haben die
Feuerpfeile Feuerpfeile sind immer sehr angesagt das triggert mich ja immer total
Feuerpfeile triggern mich immer hat
Das ist vom setting ja eher was was ich von obsidian erwarten würde
Ich verbinde mit denen ja eigentlich eher irgendwelche rpg ist
Das denn das sieht cool aus
Kein vorher game bitte nicht ja
Kein vorher game please
Okay
Jetzt hat mich ein bisschen an heroes of might and magic erinnert falls das noch jemand kennt
Bestimmt
Warm Up
Ah ouioué
Das Lot
And this is quite powerful
Excellent
Our first game spans 30 years in the American Southwest
It's a story about family, resilience and sacrifice
Moment, das ist ein anderes Game jetzt
Moment
Das ist ein anderes Game worüber die jetzt spricht gerade
Trying to find their way in a world they don't fit in
Das ist ein anderes Game
I hope you enjoyed the trailer
Ich dachte jetzt kommt noch was zu dem davor
Das hat mich verwirrt
Sieht aus wie Greta
Oder?
So wird es ein bisschen
Climate Change Simulator
Hell yeah
Zwei FPS Game
Hat mich jetzt nicht so geflasht
Das hat es nicht gebraucht finde ich
Ich fand den ersten Teil nicht schlecht
Wenn auch das Gameplay gesackt hat
Aber ich finde das Game hätte kein Nahfeuer gebraucht
Moment
War das erste nicht auch schon?
Nee, war es nicht
Wie gesagt, ich finde es hätte keinen zweiten Teil gebraucht
Die hätten auch durchaus den Game machen können
In die Richtung
Im Hintergrund ist das Soundtrack vom End Fight
Sofern man das so nennen kann
Ich weiß nicht
Da müssen sie mich echt überzeugen von dass es sich lohnt
Da einen zweiten Teil zu machen
Der sieht schon so exzellent aus
Die gibt es noch
Die haben ja Dinge hier
Wie hieß das Game nochmal?
Brutal Legends war das doch
Von Double Fine und Jack Black
Das ist aber auch schon 10 Jahre her
Okay, das ist nicht Brutal Legends
Oh
Jetzt geht es nicht
Jetzt gibt es gleich Strike
Monka Toss
Jetzt muss ich den Watt löschen danach
Siehe einfach den Gesang dann passen
Man sich soll drüber schwätzen
Dass kein Monka Toss ist
Ich finde die Musik nicht schlecht
Das ist eher Pepe Please
Ich habe jetzt gerade vergessen wie sie heißen
Wie heißen die Band von ihm nochmal?
Mit dem anderen
Die sind gar nicht schlecht
Wie heißen die nochmal?
Jack Black Band
Tenacious D genau
Die finde ich eigentlich ganz gut
Einzige was mir Tenacious D auf den Sack geht ist
Im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes
Das gefühlt 90% der Texte über Schwänze und Eier und Ärsche gehen
Dabei könnten die das besser
Mal ist das ja ganz lustig
Aber 90% muss auch nicht sein
Ich finde die
So finde ich das gut
Das sollten die alle so machen
Game kurz gelabert
Nächstes Game
So muss es sein
Ohne Stadia
All New
Das ist so eine Formulierung
Die haben die extrem gerne auf solchen Ankündigungs Events
Die sagen immer gerne All New
All New hier All New da
All New
Destiny 2 soll sich ja richtig gut gemacht haben
Ich kann nichts zu sagen weil ich habe es nicht gespielt
Ich habe das gelesen ja
Dass ich das wohl ganz gut gemacht haben muss
Und jetzt ist es ja auch Activation frei
Spiel einer von euch Destiny 2
Und das ganz ohne Stadia
Halo war ganz am Anfang der Dekan
Void Danny das habe ich noch gar nicht gesehen
Void Danny sagt was meinen die immer mit Smart Delivery unten rechts
Wahrscheinlich nicht dass es per Drohne zugestellt wird oder so
Ne keine Ahnung
Guck hier da ist Ebaro wieder Big Brain
Man bekommt es für beide Konsolen
50.000 Leute lebten hier
Und jetzt ist es eine Ghost Town
Ghost of Duty 4 Re-Imagine-Mastered
Was
Dieser Bubble hat mich gerade ein bisschen an Quantum Break erinnert
Aber wird es nicht sein
Wobei ich echt gerne einen zweiten Teil davon hätte
Wenn es Quantum Break wäre aber ist es nicht
Aber das wäre geil
Was ist das denn
Das sieht übrigens Monarch S aus
Stalker 2
Da gibt es echt noch mal einen Nachfolger
Das Stalker ist das ist wie alt ist das
15 Jahre oder so das ist uralt Stalker
Das ist so alt
Stalker Release Date muss ich mal kurz gucken
Aber das hat echt schon lange einen Nachfolger verdient
Warhammer
Irgendwas mit Inquisitor und wenn schon Warhammer drin steht muss das Warhammer 40 Billiarden sein
Okay man hat ja so gut wie nichts davon gesehen
Da wird ja premiert heute
Was ist schon alles für Warhammer Games gibt ja
Leider sacken die meisten
Was
What is happening
TikTok für Xbox Series X
Gleich kommt Doktor Disrespect
Jetzt exklusiv TikTok auf Xbox Series X
Keine Ahnung
Okay es ist auf jeden Fall irgendein Xbox Ding
So mit den Kacheln auch
Und dem Grün
Tetris
Xbox Live Tetris
Jetzt Seriously Tetris
Irgendwie sehen die Dimensionen der Figur ein bisschen un proportional aus
Was macht die Dubstep Musik da im Hintergrund
Die Musik passt überhaupt nicht dabei
Tentakel
Okay hat mich null angesprochen
Blober
Wow
Okay das ist wieder irgendein Game wo jemand einen Dachschaden hat
Das merkt man schon am Anfang
Ist das irgendein Resident Evil oder so
Irgendein Resident Evil Spinoff
Ich glaube nicht
Ne ne irgendwas anderes
Das könnte fast was von Remedys sein so gestört wie das aussieht
Hat man schon gesehen welcher Entwickler das ist
Aber es sieht eigentlich nicht gut genug aus
Oder nicht irgendwie Remedy style-ig genug aus
Okay
Sonic Olympische Spiele irgendwie sowas
Ah ne Moment das ist ja mit Mario das kann ja nicht auf der Xbox kommen
Ich hab mich vertan
Kein Sonic
Monster Hunter
50 Billionen
Patrick ist das Xenoplade
Könnte das Xenoplade sein
Phantasy Star
Stimmt Xenoplade ist ja nicht Sega oder Phantasy Star
Phantasy Star könnte tatsächlich Sega sein
Xenoplade ist auch Nintendo
Ja da kann man schon ein bisschen durcheinander kommen
Das ist hier eher was für unsere Aja Ja Fans
Das passt lustigerweise ziemlich gut zur Musik finde ich
Phantasy Star online okay
Ist Phantasy Star nicht so ein Game
Was das erste Phantasy Star war das nicht irgendwie so ein
Eines der ersten MMOs die auf Konsole liefen
Und irgendwie vor
Ah oui oui
Remedy
Zeig mal her
Was Crossfire X Campaign
Crossfire X
What the fuck geht fort
Crossfire
Can Remedy please gescheite Games machen
Es waren fast alle Remedy Games richtig poggers
Aber Crossfire ich weiß nicht
Das ist so ein wir wollen in Call of Duty sein im Singleplayer
Wir wollen so eine Mischung aus Crysis und Call of Duty
Und ne ich weiß nicht
Crossfire war das war so ein
Pay to win Cheater verseuchter CS abklatscht ja
Okay okay also die müssten sich die müssten sich ich
Ich fände das richtig cool wenn es nicht
Crossfire gewesen wäre
Aber die müssten mich echt überzeugen von Crossfire
Ah jetzt ist es fertig ja
Oh das haben sich von Apple abgeguckt
Okay es kann schon mal nicht dieses
Merkwürdige Amazon MMO sein
Weil das wäre keine Welt Premiere
Vom Setting könnte es tatsächlich Fable sein
Schreck
Also Fable
Jetzt ist fertig
Ultra nice ich fand das richtig gut die Vorstellung
Doch ich fand das richtig gut nicht unbedingt
So sehr den nicht unbedingt so sehr der Inhalt da waren vielleicht zwei drei Sachen dabei die ich ganz gut fand wie es ausgeschaut hat und wo ich mich jetzt
Wo ich mal gespannt drauf bin aber ich finde das Format nicht schlecht
Weil dieses ganze rumgelabere
Was sie da sonst immer machen wie krass exited zu sind und
World First und reimagined und reinvented und ultra exited und was auch immer
Den ganzen Scheiß kann man sich einfach sparen
Und einfach zeigen was Sache ist
Nee diesmal nicht die haben einfach nur ein paar Games nacheinander gezeigt das das Format fand ich wirklich nicht schlecht
Games habe ich jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig überzeugt die meisten aber gut das ist ja bei allem so
Nee kein Geschwätze einfach nur jetzt eine Stunde ungefähr Games gezeigt
So eigentlich richtig nice das fand ich nicht schlecht
Irgendwie hatte TV Anteil gefehlt TV also wenn du TV sehen willst wenn du TV sehen willst können wir uns nochmal
Xbox 2013 angucken
Nur mal so zum Vergleich
Ladies and gentlemen introducing Xbox one
TV experience TV TV and movies TV Xbox watch TV TV TV
TV TV watch TV TV TV TV remote TV experience TV TV TV TV TV TV TV TV TV
TV TV TV TV TV TV TV TV
Xbox go home
Das war ja das Meme schlechthin Xbox go home
Da haben sie sich noch jahrelang drüber lustig gemacht
Xbox go home TV TV TV TV
Sports Sports Sports Sports Sports Sports Sports Sports Sports Sports Sports TV TV TV TV TV TV TV
Xbox is about to become the next water cooler
Television Television
Die Halo Community enrollings bis heute nicht gibt TV TV TV TV TV TV TV TV TV TV 여기 TV TV TV TV TV TV TV TV TV TV TV TV TV TV TV TV TV TV TV TV TV TV TV TV TV TV TV TV TV TV TV TV TV TV TV TV TV TV TV TV tv
Fisch K.i habt ihr's gesehen da war
Die Fisch K.i
K Yep es ist ein Hund einer vor denregenden
Einen AD explained
Einen HUND STOPP Einen свои Hilfsmodelle
Edward
ugh
짠
Xbox G go home
Okay nice, gut da haben sie sich nicht so die blödsinn gegeben heute.
Warum kann man sich nicht mehr timeout mit channel points kann man, allerdings ging das
noch nie automatisch, sondern es muss immer noch einen mod machen und wenn gerade kein
mod da ist kannst du auch nicht timeoutet werden.
Also das ist eigentlich nur gbait, dass das so automatisch aussieht.
Naja ich fand das format echt nicht schlecht, ganz ehrlich, so sollten sie das alle machen.
Kein langes sinnloses im kreis gelaber und kein unnötiges sich selbst gefeiere einfach
games zeigen, klar es hätte noch ein bisschen mehr gameplay sein können ein bisschen meckern
kann man ja immer, aber einfach games zeigen, ein paar worte zu sagen und nächstes, finish.
Wenn es nach mir geht hätten sie sich auch dieses ganze world premiere, console launch
premiere, console exclusive, blaa premiere hätten sie sich aussparen können.
Was macht eigentlich die gamescom dieses jahr?
Was sieht es eigentlich mit der gamescom aus dieses jahr?
Die wollten doch die gamescom online machen oder?
Das guckt doch doch keine sau an.
Das ist wieder so ein ding, ich glaube das kriegen wir nicht gebacken.
Da kommt dann wieder unsere digitalen ministerin an mit dem ganz merkwürdigen kleid und steht
irgendwie ein bisschen deplatziert rum.
Wer ist denn das, die cortana spielen soll?
Ich habe schon mal irgendwo gesehen, cortana ist jetzt, ah cortana nicht die gleiche sprecherin
die früher auch peach gesprochen hat?
Chat jetzt können wir noch was lernen, ich glaube schon, voice actor peach, ich glaube
die haben früher peach gesprochen.
Na das ist doch was, cortana, toad und todette.
Ja nicees event leute, ich werde heute nicht sonderlich alt werden, ich bin übelst kaputt,
ich bin eigentlich nur angekommen, weil heute dieses xbox event war und ich mache immer
noch gerade diese komische microsoft azure schulung, das geht halt bis 17 uhr und danach
bin ich übelst kaputt, da ist so viel heiße luft dabei und gefühlt ist das nur an der
oberfläche gegratzt, das könnte man besser machen, aber wenn ich bis 17 uhr mir da zugetextet
werde habe ich keinen bock jetzt dann mich hier noch mal 4 stunden vor den rechner zu
setzen oder so, aber morgen ist der letzte tag, ne ich mache kein zertifikat.
Also ich kriege bestimmt ein teilnahme zertifikat oder sowas, aber das ist ja kein zertifikat
im eigentlichen sinne.
Ich weiß jetzt übrigens auch warum die leute die ganzen azure schulungen mitmachen, dass
du die prüfung machen kannst, musst du irgendwelche sterne sammeln und diese sterne kriegst du
nur wenn du prüfung gemacht hast, äh wenn du schulung gemacht hast, das ist quasi ein
sich selbst versorgendes ehm schulungs und und geldsystem.
Die verschaffen, die beschaffen sich untereinander geld quasi dann, microsoft die schulungsleute
und dann wieder die microsoft, dann wieder schulungsleute und dann schulungsteilnehmern.
Was soll, was soll denn so eine azure lootbox drin sein, ein windows phone, doctor evil cookie
5 monat, exellent, dankeschön.
Ich grind jetzt noch ne runde poe hier, aber nicht on stream, das wird zwar anstrengend.
Morgen ist der letzte tag, morgen ist die schulung offiziell 15 uhr fertig, also sie
geht bis 17 uhr, 15 uhr ist fertig, danach machen sie noch 2 stunden prüfungsvorbereitung,
aber nachdem ich keine prüfung machen will, bin ich 15 uhr durch, dann kann ich morgen
vielleicht mal wieder ganz normales zeug streamen, weil es gibt schon ein paar sachen, die man
sich angucken muss.
Trotzdem schön, dass spontan so viele leute am start waren, wir sehen uns morgens spätest,
also alle spätestens am sonntag, da bin ich ja eh immer am start, aber wahrscheinlich
morgen übermorgen, und dann gucken wir mal, dann machen wir wieder das übliche, wir basteln
irgendwelche technikkrams oder gucken uns irgendwelche lielungsgeschichten an, oder
ich hab mir eine kamera gekauft für ähm, also nicht wirklich rl sachen, also sowas
was man am tisch, was ich dann auch mal am tisch festmachen könnte, bzw. auf den stativ
stellen könnte, da könnte man mal was zusammellöten im stream oder so, allerdings muss ich dann
aufpassen, dass ich mich nicht leake.
Silikonmaske, das behebt natürlich die probleme sofort.
Kennst du das openit cockpit, nein, das hört sich aber irgendwie nach so nem rum, ne, das
kenn ich nicht, ahhh nagios, also nagios forks, oh oh oh, und kreis.
Ich bin bis heute am rätseln was die mehrzahl von nagios ist, ist es nagiose, ist es nagii?
heiße kommentare das wichtigste immer etwas sehr magerer bericht exzellent nagieren man
weiß es nicht es ist php es sieht zumindest mal ansatzweise modern aus wobei man halt sagen
muss die grafen ist nichts anderes wie quasi einen grafana iframe sieht zumindest sehr danach aus
das gar nicht so übel ist
was kleines einfaches könnte das vielleicht gar nicht so schlecht sein vielleicht vielleicht
gucken wir uns das mal an ich ich ich speichere mir das mal ich muss mir das allerdings mal in
ruhe anschauen ohne stream 4 also wir sehen uns bis denn macht es gut nächster stream morgen
spätestens sonntag aber wahrscheinlich morgen übermorgen bis denn macht's gut zu